this is camponotus Hokulea knows the
site of the black carpenter ant must be
terrifying to other ant species the
carpenter ant can be up to 1.6
centimeters long making it europe's
biggest species it likes to live in
rotting wood it eats flies and
mosquitoes and if you bother it it will
bite you and dealer Martin Sebesta
things pants make cute pets it's fast
enough info Bahamas what's fascinating
about ants is their social life there is
constant communication among them they
create something together they expand
the nest or bring in food or share the
food they have different occupations and
it's always fascinating to watch them
mosey fustian sebesta a trained
industrial mechanic has been fascinated
by hands since he was a teenager in 2003
he opened up his own and chopped in
berlin the first in germany it is more
than 20 species they come from all over
the world sebesta has between ten and
twenty thousand colonies in stock that
includes some exotic species like the
south american leaf cutter ant which can
carry 30 times its own body weight the
leaves feet up fungus which in turn
becomes the ants dinner just booze on
the bottom touch the leaf cutter ants
nests can be so huge in nature they can
be as large as 50 square meters and 8
meters deep venous open for a comedic
ruse off sometimes private owners can no
longer handle the colony after two years
why should we get them in touch with the
zoo that needs to be considered besos no
Scotsman off in four books testing
Zoltan Bianca svenska also has a
fondness for exotic ants the biology
teacher has 16 different species in her
Berlin apartment for example the South
American patch I condola apcalis an
aggressive predator that stings like a
wasp
could this be the ideal house pet skip
kushina gonna there are a number of
reasons why I think it's a good pet I
can create a beautiful landscape I can't
do that with a dog or a cat garbage kind
of lunch after hold I am fascinated by
this mini ecosystem equals team
finishing deshpande dt low-cost neoteny
it isn't expensive to feed ants just a
few grasshoppers and sugar water and
they're not loud loud so they are a
comparatively inexpensive pet though a
queen from this Australian species costs
160 euros and there is another
disadvantage to keeping ants the exotic
species cannot legally be allowed into
the domestic ecosystem one set Sigma
swallow Mars it refers you should ask
are these ants under some form of legal
protection is the species endangered you
shouldn't try to maintain a colony if
the species is endangered and non-common
additions and then are there any permits
required Australia is very strict about
what you can bring into or out of the
country halt skid so a beginner
shouldn't start with an exotic species
but a domestic one like these ants
Martin sebesta produces and sells
starter sets from 50 euros up
Sylvester delivers the ants with two
terrariums and all the necessary
equipment one Queen and one worker ant
are enough to produce a colony of
thousands let's and ultimately we see
ants outdoors but we don't see what they
do inside their nest we just seen and
dragging something into it but then what
happens if I open or destroy an ant nest
all I see is a swarming thronged a
mutton and that's why Martin's avesta
regards the ant as the best house pet
his shop now has 10 employees they take
orders and send ants all over Europe
you
you